and they were finishing the card so
let's let's make it a little bit about
where we started and where de carros
tried to go we spent last class talking
a lot about God and we're going to talk
a little bit about God this class but
now we're going to talk a little bit
more about the human being himself or
herself itself we're the date card said
alive what was his first worry then yeah
in meditation one what was the first
thing you got concerned about what to
call his new book wasn't that what was
he concerned about this will put it all
in perspective
he was worried about what he was
accurate about so whether whether he was
in touch with do you remember there were
a lot of things he was worried about
meditation woman what was the first
thing he got I was not upset but
interest in figuring out no come a
little bit later he is interested in
whether God exists not not it seems
because they cartage really into God or
anything like that
yes so if we're mind and body or spirit
and body or soul and body whatever you
want to call it the external world that
we perceive we're proceeding through our
senses or hearing me right now right if
somebody watching this video would be
hearing seeing things through their eyes
through their ears it's not going
directly into their brain sort of
capability
sometimes our senses are wrong right
what are some of those cases you know
the stick that goes in the water wall no
it's not actually changing its its
configuration right see the Mirage just
you're driving and the hot summer and
water it's not actually in water but
then he's got a bigger worry what if
this is all in a dream that's a bigger
worry than just you know my food once in
a while that's sort of like saying am I
in a perpetual magic show or somebody
else is screwing with me all the time
deceiving me or maybe I'm deceiving
myself maybe I'm actually in the same
and this is all just some sort of
nightmare I'm really in a Asylum
somewhere or I'm hallucinating or I mean
somebody else's dream or you know there
was a movie like this fairly recently
maybe I'm a character and somebody's
normal there's all sorts of
possibilities and all of those with the
external world into doubt they even put
if we go far enough with them they put
our body into dump maybe we don't
actually have bodies
maybe we're almost disembodied souls in
somewhere or glitches in a computer
program or who knows so what we want to
do for good Cartesians
first we want to doubt and then we want
to put the world back together why does
he stop at God on the way doesn't that
seem like kind of a strange move to make
if your whole goal is to get into the
external world and things in the
external world one bring up God well
first let's think about some of the
things in the external world that we we
care about so what are some of the
things here this room just look around
computers yeah and so computers we've
got this chair right here right
coffee cups patties chalk now these are
all what we call objects right and we
want to know about them I mean I would
like to think that this is not just some
sort of you know programming a larger
computer program that I'm experiencing
right now when I go and eat dinner I
don't want to think that I did a matrix
and I'm eating fake whatever it is that
we're having for dinner I'm not even
sure yet because we haven't planned very
well for the week what else is in the
world what else is in this classroom
besides just plain old objects something
more important something more valuable
so knowledge that's in the classroom but
where were the knowledge being human
beings we're interested in other human
beings and other human beings likewise
how do we know other human beings do we
have a direct mind mind connection how
do you know me through my body right
through what you here's the feel how do
you know anybody else in this classroom
true through their body through your
senses you are perceiving them you don't
you don't have direct access to my mind
or my soul any more than I do to you you
know we have signs of this when I assign
you a paper and I said I want to see
that you understand this demonstrate it
to me how do you do it you actually put
it well you don't write it out by hand
probably any of you you're all my
computer generation so you type it out
on your computer but that's physical
right how do you know that any of that
stuff really exists would it be terrible
to find all these other people and made
up something that God or some sadistic
demon as as put in your way just to
screw with you that make you fake cuz
that's the way I've seen everybody else
well those everybody else wouldn't be
real people with that how do you know
that you are then well that's okay so
now we're going along in the process
right that's where we have the coachee
Joe if this is one thing that I can I
can say about myself and you can say
about yourself and Descartes could say
about himself I have to exist if I'm
being deceived there has to be a need to
be deceived so even if I am asleep today
just some of these figment of their
imagination I do exist I have some some
reality I have a substance whether other
people part of that or not get Kurtz's
you can't be sure about that yeah we're
still in the hyperbolic down we haven't
gotten to that point yet so what could
give us the possibility of real
knowledge
well let's think about God for that
Descartes ended up trying to prove that
that God exists and maybe to accept
Islam his proof maybe don't we're not so
much interested in whether you
individually accept that proof or not or
find it convincing we're interested in
what my logistic are trying to get out
of it and what do you remember about
what he what he thinks about God he
thinks God exists right what does he
think God is what does he call God what
are the terms of uses for the
characteristics that got yes there was
an soul right the card of doing
something a little bit different the
card actually like I put it out last
class you'd said something about God
that the an Psalm says I'm not using
that in later and of course I'm thinking
about God but I'm not saying that God is
this my trying to argue for it what do
you say God was
he's not very different than other
theists philosophers philosophers who
believe that God exists
he's got good or bad thumbs up yeah he
says God is actually good he's all good
what else do you know about powerful is
all would you say the prime mover is
that a center distance no it's a curtain
that's that's Aristotle there that's
Thomas Aquinas that's okay
does he agree with that just a current
agree that God is a prime mover yeah he
thinks that God created everything once
it creates any sort of de cartes God
doesn't do an awful lot he preserves
things in being oh yeah I think that you
could you could be a datus and go along
with what Descartes says we're probably
Aristotle to Aristotle's gun is not a
very involved in human affairs but but
they they have them there to get
everything going somewhat in different
ways it card is more interesting card is
less interested in the metaphysics what
got everything going and more interested
in can we know anything for certain this
is where the goodness comes in since God
is good but God is not going to be a
deceiver because to deceive people
that's bad right in Jeff I mean if you
wanted to kill all your classmates and
you came in here with God and I said hey
look over there there's a monster I'd be
telling a lie right but I might distract
you long enough that bus could jump on
you and
would that be a bi deception that would
be a good deception right but God's not
in those sort of situations I mean the
inhibit ins that kind of takes care of
that doesn't so if God is you know just
screwing with us setting things up for
us to always fail that histologically in
terms of knowledge God wouldn't be God
God would be something like that evil
demon that that Descartes was
hypothesize about if God is supremely
perfect God's not going to be a deceiver
so what's the upshot of that
foreknowledge that means that some of
our knowledge of the external world and
the way it works it could be reliable so
take comfort a card if you can't prove
that God exists or you can't assume that
God exists or you don't know something
like out of the picture you can't really
know anything with certainty but once
you've got God out of the picture now
you can start building everything back
up you guys see how that how these fit
together now one of the things I want to
point out to you with this the card has
been accused of engaging in a circular
argument you guys know what a circular
argument is what's a circular argument
well they can be solved well it keeps
repeating itself innocent if the
argument itself doesn't repeat itself
but the parts the way they're arranged
in relation to each other
one part is required to prove another
part but that part is being proved but
the first of all I'll give you an
example again with God right so I'm
gonna say God exists how do you know
that well the Bible says
there we go
okay what's the problem with that does
everybody agree that well if it's in the
Bible it must be true
you have to back that up by saying the
Bible's true right and then usually if
you say how do you know the Bible's true
well God broke it right so it must be
true and it says in there that God
exists so God must exist which is what
you need in order to think that the
Bible is true and it just keeps going in
one big circle like that right now these
things could be true these all could
actually be true statements that's not
the bad part of the argument the bad
part is that the way they are goes up
it's a big circle what Descartes
actually needs is something that you
might say is in the external world or
maybe it's in our minds that things that
we actually perceive as clear and
distinct are actually true where we can
have knowledge about that because think
about winning if you try to prove God's
existence there was an important point
that I think I stressed to you where he
was making an assumption about causes
and effects do you remember that he made
the assumption that if you have an
effect the cause has to have at least as
much reality as the effect now how did
you know
didn't he doubt everything do you
remember in the meditations in improving
that that principle to you she's kind of
brought it in didn't he maybe didn't
catch that the first time through before
maybe the second time the third time
however many times have you read it
bless you there's a lot of these in
these texts that I don't catch you know
first year ten times that I I read them
if you have to assume some principles
that are out there in the world or in
the universe that a good God would have
created and you need those to prove that
God exists then there's something like a
circularity there isn't they call this
the Cartesian Circle but if you if you
accept it let's say we get past that
what the current talks about our clear
and distinct ideas anything that I can
have clear and distinct ideas oh well I
really understand and I've broken it
down into its bits then I can have
knowledge of so God's not a deceiver I
do seem to know some things about the
world about mathematics about causality
about metaphysics I can trust those
things they current say
maybe I can even get to other people I
could say you know if the co detail
works for me what's gonna happen to me
the cart doesn't go there he's he's not
that worried about that we're probably
more worried about that than he is but
that's that's something we're thinking
about now this is up kind of a problem
so if God is good and God exists and God
set up everything and I now have a way
in which I can tell whether I'm on track
with things how is it possible that I
ever get deceived how is it possible
that I've been taken in by things and
this is where he gets to another
distinction and we've talked a little
bit about the will before but the will
is going to be very very important in
the rest of the meditations when we talk
about your will what do we mean it's all
of you have a will it's part of what got
you here today I don't mean like a will
like you know inter safety deposit box
about you know what's gonna happen to
yours I understand your car things like
that I mean part of you what is your
will or if we say you have free will
what does that mean
you have the capacity to choose right
you have choices but if you were like a
robot it wouldn't matter whether you
can't choice like a robot could you know
walk this way or walk that way but its
programming tells it you have to go this
way
you're not like those are you
good-looking you're you're unique among
animals other animals have wills but
they're not free wills dog you know does
it have a choice whether it loves its
puppies are not that's instinct we can't
look at them as if they they have a free
will the way that we do but you know
dogs are pretty pretty conditioned and
they're pretty simple animals even even
you know if it's debatable where you get
to chimpanzees and things like that but
all of you have a free will those are
matter of fact let's say that you
realized something about yourself that
you don't like something about your
behavior something you know things have
you've chosen to do so far what are your
options
what did people do in those sort of sort
of circumstances you realize that you're
too mean to people or that you take
people for granted or take more than
your fair share of the cake that's given
to you it's sort of things you do you've
all done something you've all dealt with
something like this in your lifetime
changed your habits how did what do you
do yeah if it's a really different
relationship matter and relationships
are damaged you have to do work and who
chooses whether you do that work you do
right you know you have the freedom to
change the course of your will if your
habits are making you go this way and
you want to change it you have the
freedom to actually say hey this is the
wrong way I need to start going this way
although usually what happens is here
you're going this way they say I got to
change this and you're now going still
this way right for a while and then
finally change your habits when you're
going the right way
your will is is really interesting it
has the capacity not only to judge
everything out there in the universe and
to make your body do it at once your
will has the capacity to make itself do
what it wants and even if you feel like
you're not making a choice
you still make a choice if you have a
difficult decision to make
and you say I'm going to put it off
until tomorrow that's a choice right if
you say I can't decide at all I'm gonna
let somebody else decide you decided to
let somebody else decide didn't you
that's your will nothing else except for
maybe God you have what we call radical
freedom this is why this is such an
exciting time for you guys because you
get to choose the person that you're
gonna become when you get to be my age
you can still change yourself but it's a
bit harder it's certainly the body is a
lot harder to change but even the mental
habits you know if I decide okay I'm
going to be a morning person from now on
which I'm not I could do that it would
take an awful lot of willing over and
over again to change the way that I I
typically do that is to change my
choices that I make so you have this
capacity of will and it's basically
infinite apparent sense the only thing
that can constrain your will ultimately
is your own rhythm if somebody holds a
gun you're headed so give me your money
remember we talked about this with
Aristotle right somebody holds a gun to
your head and says we're going to the
ATM you're going to take all your money
out
could you refuse could you say screw you
I'm not going to do it yeah you have
that choice you have the capacity to do
that anyone who matters can choose to
study anything you want right I mean you
know there will be repercussions if you
if you decide to study physics and we're
good at math you're gonna have a hard
time right if you go into fashion
merchandising and you really hate you
know magazines like like Cosmo and Marie
Claire you're gonna have a rough time
but you do have the choice anything that
you want to know that's in that library
over there nothing stopping nothing
could stop you if you choose to do it
you at least have the capacity to choose
you don't necessarily determine whether
it's going to be successful but you know
the capacity
choose anything you want if you want to
think about something you can choose
that too if you even want to think that
that true things are false and false
things are true you can make yourself do
that if you want to believe that all
politicians are liars and cheats and
stuff like that that can't possibly be
true beauty you could make yourself
believe that or if you want to make
yourself believe all some of your coffee
my grandparents generation you know they
used to do when they were kids to deal
with coughs they gargle with kerosene
sounds kind of crazy right but you could
think that that's true you could make
yourself think that that's true if you
worked out it hard enough don't know why
you want to do it but you could make
yourself do that and you can make
yourself America with kerosene if you
wanted to you have the capacity to will
all these things so your will is as
Descartes says pretty much infinite what
about the rest of your mind is your
imagination infinite can you imagine
anything that you possibly want to maybe
I find my imagination rather constrained
there are some things I can't imagine
like Descartes talks about a thousand
sided figure can you can you call the
thousands I had a figure in your mind so
like a pentagon it's five sided figure
and a hexagon is a six sided figure call
of a thousand sided figure can you do
that probably not I mean you could make
like something that has a whole bunch of
angles but how do you know it's a
thousand minutes you can actually tell
them well that means that your your
imagination is restricted Isabel what
about your senses can you perceive
everything
actually you you perceive most of the
things that go on around you
most of what we take in through our
senses we filter out otherwise are we
doing the same one of the reasons why
the researchers think that autistic kids
are less interested in human beings and
therefore lack social skills because
they're so interested in the things that
they're actually seeing or experiencing
they're taking it more sensitive and
they're fascinated by they're almost you
might say imprisoned by okay what about
your intellect your understanding the
thing that's like the highest part of it
is that infinite do any of you like know
everything that God does okay will any
of you ever know everything that God
does or let's set the bar a lot lower
right who can compete with God who's the
smartest person like maybe a celebrity
here
Eric could be somebody on TV
anyway you want
surely must have some ideas women smart
right
what are you watching - sableye crystals
really bright all of you watch - you're
right anybody here who doesn't watch TV
you don't watch TV at all not really or
not at all okay who's this who's the
smart sports person who gets paid to sit
up there and true the fat about you know
why the Bears won and I was bad I mean
this is kind of a good example of your
intellect snap meeting unlimited anyway
if you can't bring to mind somebody who
you think it's smart clearly there's
some some gaps in your life so far could
you feel all those in what do you think
how do you feel about this when you guys
are students this is your whole job
right now is to sort of improve your
intellects sure you know prepare
yourself for a career and all that but
really what they're gonna fire you for
is your brains hydrator your winning
personality your good looks of your
great connections that may help you get
a job what's gonna keep you in that job
in today's workplace
how smart could you get what do you
think how smart suppose student beware
they get out in Paris
let me ask that much what do you think
you should know
besides the answers to questions that I
keep throwing at you but what's
important for you guys to it's a master
say something
what do you think is important for you
to master yeah okay I think that's a
good place to start right if you get out
of here and you're majoring in something
and you don't know anything about it if
you need to get done something happened
that that didn't you know didn't go
right yeah I mean here your intellect
your mind should be greatly improved by
the time that you get out of here about
whatever it is you're supposed to be
passionate about studying will that help
you know about everything what if you
spent all your time in that library that
I mean all your time all you did was was
come to class go back to your dorms we
go to the cafeteria eat and then
everything else is done in that library
you'd learn a lot right would you would
you be much closer to like infinite
knowledge I always get depressed I go to
the library you know why because I've
been reading my whole life I've been
reading since I was like three and I've
been studying philosophy since I was 16
or so and I walked down like you know
one stack of philosophy books and I'm
like I'm never gonna have the chance to
even read most of these and know what's
going out of them let alone you know the
ones that I read actually figure out
what's in the book and follow along with
it and then remember it the next week
after I put the book down to me that's
kind of depressing that means that I'm
very very restrictive maybe you guys
know earlier long maybe it won't work um
then but still our impacts are very
limited are there so if our intellect is
limited but our will isn't there has
certain ramifications
you can believe things you can choose to
believe things or you can choose to take
a position on things with Descartes
cause of judgment without actually
knowing it so when you were having a
dream then youth lock of dream was real
what was going on there your intellect
all the intellect does is has ideas it
doesn't actually tell you that those
ideas are true or false or anything like
that it just has ideas and they're put
together in certain ways it's your will
that comes out and says yes this is this
is real or no this is not real this is
true this is false so if you allow your
your will to outstrip your intellect if
you allow it to go beyond what you
actually understand with clear and
distinct ideas then you're going to have
trouble then you're going to believe
things that aren't true so let's let's
think for a minute just about some
examples of this they don't have to be
Cartesian examples think about your
day-to-day life how many of you who have
been in a relationship
you know that sort of thing these days
friend with benefits significant out
there whatever how do you know that they
weren't cheating on you you don't yeah I
mean you just okay so when you trust
somebody you are making a choice right
I'm not saying that you shouldn't I'm
just saying what the curve would say
unless you actually know you shouldn't
commit yourself so your attitude towards
the boyfriend/girlfriend of you hey you
know so far I haven't found any evidence
that they cheated on me I'm open to you
know revising my thing one way or the
other there's probably no way that
anybody could ever convince you that
they would never cheat on you
other than maybe going through a lot of
tests
what about products you guys eat it a
lot of things right drink a lot of
different things how many of you buy
groceries maybe buy groceries at this
point no you all get in the cafeteria or
when you're going home you're going to
eat you know and mom and dad's or uncle
CEOs or whoever whoever it's a place
you're going to so how do you know that
food is healthy you believe that is
right nobody you don't think anyone's
giving you bad food right or do you
think the cafeterias give me good I
don't know have you been like look have
you gone you know I looked around we're
going to see what what they they put in
the food I looked at the cans boxes and
see you know what the ingredients are
videos today that's always kind of iffy
because the bureau says pressed me
what's it supposed to be it's supposed
to be beef and lamb right you don't know
what's beef and lamb do you
I be you know soybeans who knows
now type of meat they use so light to
fill on me how did you actually know if
you don't know what Descartes would say
don't say that you know just say I think
it might be this way
but I don't really know adopt a sort of
intellectual humility or skepticism
about things if you do that Descartes
says then you're not going to find
yourself believing in things that turn
out later on to be false you're never
going to be deceived you actually have
the choice this is what you might call
an ethics of the use of the mind now the
question would be do you actually want
to live it that way would you like to
look at other beings out of the world
and say well I don't know that Mister is
not actually an Android can't because
we'll be sure I'm just gonna you know
treat it as if he's not for the you know
competing with hold by a sense I don't
know would you want to live like that
take her thought that was the way to go
you thought that's better than believing
in a lot of things you don't actually
know our true what can you be sure about
that well Dickert says there are some
things in the external world that you
can't actually be pretty sure about and
he's got this idea about what we call it
and this is a meditation v he calls them
true and immutable nature's objects
you know think about geometry for
example you guys all remember in high
school geometry it's probably pretty
boring cuz you do a lot of proofs
if it was like my geometry class so
you've forgotten most of what we learned
there because it was actually boring and
you don't remember what we wore right
what were you actually dealing with
there you were dealing with the basic
building blocks of physical reality
triangles circles those sorts of things
lines planes all of that those things
have certain natures that's why we can
teach a geometry class that's why we can
have the same results over and over and
over again how do you know that a
triangle yeah not only has three angles
with that those three angles add up to
180 degrees
you probably don't remember any proofs
about that right does anyone any
remember that I don't but I believe it
why do I believe it I think that's part
of the essence of what it is to be a
triangle do you or do you think maybe
triangles have 176 degrees maybe they
vary maybe they can whatever you want
well if you if you think about the
nature of triangle if you don't actually
have to look at triangles in the world
to do this again why we can do geometry
you can actually consult things in your
mind these Truman immutable nature's are
actually in your mind
they're what Descartes calls they
correspond to what they are calls it a
ideas ideas that you are born with you
don't you don't start thinking about
triangles as soon as you're you know
born or anything that these ideas you
have to be actuated they have to have
something you know call them wine this
is kind of similar to Plato isn't it and
the idea of the forum's except these are
actually in your mind and you're born
with them he talks about your mind as
being something like a Treasury or a
storehouse it's got all these ideas and
it's just waiting for you to start using
them mathematics all of those ideas are
in your mind geometry all those things
are in your mind metaphysics those are
in your mind as well it's just up to you
to actually find them and start using
them now
what do you think that would take to do
that
there's there's really two things what
is not tying yourself into projects
believing in things that may or may not
be true the other thing is to try to get
your mind away from the body don't think
of things in terms of their external
appearances think of things in terms of
their structures they're intelligible
structures again it sounds sort of like
Plato's silence or like Aristotle isn't
it the more that you do that the better
you'll get at it just like the more that
you do mathematics the better you get at
it right the more that you do athletics
with the physical things so this is what
we call in the CSIs we have we have two
things we have an ethics of the use of
the mind how you want to be using your
mind and we have what we call in the
CSIs you might think of it as a workout
program that's what the meditations in
effect are a sort of workout program for
your mind to help you see things in
certain ways ways that are more true in
Indian arts view and if you do that then
you will never be deceived again you'll
never give assent to things that aren't
true and you won't even worry about
whether you're in dream or not because
to the end of those things there are
some signs by which we can tell we're
actually
so what are you guys this is where will
happen will actually end a little bit
early today what do you make of all this
mystic art business when you're reading
the meditation did any of you walk away
from you're worried that we were stuck
in a dream sometimes there is a student
that that happens to what can you take
from this what do you plan that's maybe
useful for you
or what did you find interesting and
Descartes that's a good place to have
that they can't really believe what you
see you're like here because your senses
don't always they're not always accurate
yeah that's true
no dick Hurtz not unique and saying that
he's maybe unique in how far it goes
being more skeptical I guess of what's
around you yeah just kind of believing
what you see the funny thing is once you
start doing that it becomes all did
there didn't use a sort of risk you
start becoming skeptical one thing and
you start doubting more and more and
more and more what else anything else
that struck you and reading through this
what do you think you're going to
remember about Descartes two years ten
years I'm always interested because I
know I do this for a living I'm really
interested in what you guys are yeah
yeah we don't think that much about it
do it
yeah that's the way our everyday life is
I'm not I'm not saying by the way that
you should go home and you know start
mistrusting the turkey you're worrying
about if there's anything in the stuff
but yeah you're right there it's it's a
sort of what we call the natural
attitude this habit of just really
naively trust in things the current gets
us out of that it gets us maybe too far
just skepticism but then he brings us
back out what would happen if you took
God out of the picture of us what yeah
instead of it being God looking at like
a computer like in the matrix could you
ever trust anything other than the fact
that you exist you guys are all familiar
with that's right so it takes the you
take the red pill to the Blue Bell
remember blue blue takes you down the
rabbit hole and then there's the scene
where they pull them out of the things
and now he's no longer plugged into the
matrix
he's actually in his physical body and
his consciousness is connected with it
but couldn't that all just be like in
one bigger computer program once you
take out the assumption that your
perceptions could be realized because
there's some sort of it doesn't
necessarily be God there could be the
universe is designed in such a way
it makes sense or it's intelligible you
could take them out of the picture if
you don't have that assumption then you
could net you could never really be sure
about anything could you that by the way
is the world of the paranoiac person
who's got you know paranoid personality
disorder they you know they think that
everybody's out to get them or that some
people are out to persecute them once
you fall into that you it's very
difficult to get out so have a good
Thanksgiving